hello it's Lisa from Hardmead Farm
and I'm here to do a Q&A on one of my most popular videos
you all seem to have some really interesting questions
or some questions I keep getting recently asked
so I'm here to answer them
firstly I'm shocked about how many people are shocked that chickens are animal
yes chickens are actually animals that live
grow and have the ended
with that shocking revelation
I decide I will continue to make these videos to teach and share my knowledge
it was only generations about life
crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy
crazy crazy crazy
broken dreams with golden hands
from myself come back to you
I would like to hold my hand
how we will cry I would like to hold my little hand
how we will run will how we will question
where is
the flower
and you should be on my way
I would like to reach out my hand
that's where it's going down
no more messes
I would like to hold
my little hand
I would like to hold my little hand
I would like to hold my little heart